dans mesdames messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues monsieur le premier
ministre en montagne avant l'arrivée de
la neige la saison du des montagnes âge
est synonyme d'activités économiques
sociales et culturelles instance intense
dans nos vallées à l'automne sont
organisées dans les territoires alpins
et pyrénéens les grandes foires
agricoles celles où éleveurs maquignons
et bergers se retrouvent le temps d'une
journée pour partager les dernières
anecdotes de la saison des steve et
vendre leurs bêtes des animaux des veaux
qui n'ont pas encore connu les étables
nom des bêtes élevées en plein air avec
soin et j'ose le dire avec amour
cette année pourtant à la traditionnelle
foire tarder en duo champsaur il était
impossible d'acheter des brebis
malgré la qualité des produits locaux
malgré le soleil et les couleurs
d'automne le temps n'était pas à la fête
d'ailleurs de nombreux maires venus des
hautes-alpes et des
alpes-de-haute-provence du vaucluse des
alpes maritimes s'étaient rendus jusqu à
champoléon pour exprimer leur soutien
aux éleveurs pour interpeller les
pouvoirs publics sur une réalité qui
n'est plus tenable
en effet dans certains alpages comme
ceux situés au coeur du parc national
des écrins
il est impossible d'appliquer les
mesures de protection du plan national
d'action sur le loup et les activités
d'élevage
malgré les dispositifs d'être berger de
filet et de chaînes de protection le
loup au fil des années gagne des
territoires et aujourd'hui se pose la
question du devenir de l'agro
pastoralisme en montagne
la question n'est pas qui du ministre de
la transition écologique et solidaire ou
du ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation aura le dernier mot
non monsieur le premier ministre la
question et la france veut-elle ou non
maintenir la tradition du pastoralisme
et la vie qui va avec
[Musique]